hello how you doing man good how you
doing I guess we got some concern is
that there's some as far like alcohol
you guys been drinking this morning last
night last night last night okay you
have your driver's license registration
Insurance how long ago last
night you know was the last time we took
a drink um last
night 1230
12:30 left foot on the line
Right Foot In Front heel touching your
toes hands at your
side and when I tell you to begin you're
going to take nine Heel To Toe steps on
the
line I'm sorry hun I can't hear yet my
knees are
shaking your knees are shaking yes I I
can't do it you can't do that okay we'll
move forward
then
hello how you doing man good how you
doing I guess we got some concern is
that there some uh smells like alcohol
you guys been drinking this morning last
night last night last night okay you
give your driver's license registration
insurance I AG go last night
you know was the last time you took a
drink um last night probably 12:30
1230 answer no you're fine just
now I don't
know 106
sanus
[Applause]
high
school so you what time it was that you
drink uh 1:30 1:30 this morning okay
yeah we left we left ears around what's
that we lefts around 12 okay all right
so give me a second but I'm talking to
her real quick all right I'm sorry
you're good so do me a favor man just
step out here so I can talk to you back
stay in the car right
Bud sure come back here
so you said around 1:30 was the last
time you had a drink yeah okay all right
I just woke up and took out school who
do you take to school my niece your
niece
okay all right I'm going to do this
little thing with your eyes all right
all right you're okay with that okay all
right see tip of this right here little
black part right here all right just
want you to keep eyes on that and only
your eyes fall you understand that not
your head all right
remember with your eyes only all right
you're following with your head that's
why I'm asking I'm really nervous right
now because I just woke up and I'm I
don't you what I just woke up D think my
nie school and I don't know what's going
on right now so you smell like alcohol I
know cuz I drink last night okay do me a
favor take a seat right there for now
okay resource 106 can I get a the 106
car be reference possible single
one you want me to walk her over there I
can't hear you do you want me to walk
her over there hey there everybody so I
want to talk to you right now about our
sponsor Jed match very excited that we
partner with them and many of our true
crime fans will know exactly who they
are so Jed match is the largest public
DNA database and since 2018 Jed match
has played a crucial role in helping law
enforcement solve over a thousand cases
like the Golden State killer the NorCal
rapist the buck skin girl and this is
all because of regular everyday people
who use the service the way it works is
you take a DNA test you upload the data
to Jed match and you become a genetic
witness helping identify Killers or
unknown descendants it is 100% free to
sign up and upload and also you get all
these tools for your own genetic
geneology research which is very cool
this is just a unique way that true
crime fans can actually help fight crime
so if you want to learn more about the
genetic Witness Program and how to join
Jed match head over to
www.gedmatch.com
bodycam or click the link in the
description yeah you ready come over
here
let's go straight to
her yeah there's a guy in there I told
him to stay in the
car all right so we got flag down that
smell like alcohol she dropped off her
child she she put the window down smells
still like alcohol she said she last had
a drink at 1:30 this morning
ears I came home I went sleep I woke up
took her to school and M
it okay did you do any I just did or
anything just the eyes that's it then y
i Haven read a Miranda or anything like
that any question or anything regular
DUI you don't have
to um all right so do
you are you okay with doing some
exercises with me this morning you're
good with that all
right have a good spot to set up in this
parking lot it's so
cool um we could yeah if you want to
park between those use that whole line
right there there's an open spot right
there between two parking spots just
hang out here
man
for
I'm going P my truck around right okay
walk with me real quick right over
here yeah this is fine I got to see
where she's going to stop she to use
those lines to use it as a line
we're going to walk over here
[Applause]
right
you want just stand right in front of
this patrol car right here just stay
right here all right there good there's
good
on the ground patol park right somebody
tries to cut you off while you're
doing
this um is he good to dry uh I haven't I
haven't made contact with him I just
told him to stay in the car for an now I
don't think he's going to be good he was
out drinking with her last
night I'm going Park my patrol car
somebody tries to cut her
off Mom hey did you sign in as 106 yeah
it should be I even call it as 106 oh
they got his barwell oh
okay
sorry just guys parkw doing a
miscellaneous at at Sebastian high
school he's supposed to be off I said
well yeah he is it's Mercedes Merc is
here he goes well they got him in park
I'm like I'll check out in a minute
again on the radio well he's going to
get it St away but uh
so how did you how did this all I guess
these guys U when they dropped off the
parent I guess she assum she put the
window down I haven't really talked to
him a whole lot and she just felt like
sh all off so I walked over there and I
knocked the window she put the window
down and it just
read like when I walk
yeah and I was like you've been drinking
she was like I Dr last night when the
last time you drink she was like at 1:30
this morning I was like it's not
even what I'm saying that's the last
time was
130 I did the Gaze eyes was
boun
go back to feet together hands in your
th
okay so left foot on the
line I'm going to demonstrate and then
you're going to do it okay so you can go
ahead back feet together hands at your
sides like I said I'm going to
demonstrate first then have you do that
sound good okay so your left foot is
going to be on the line you're going to
put your right foot on the line ahead of
your
left with the heel of your right foot
against the toe of your left and you're
going to keep your hands at your sides
just like
this just like this
okay go ahead and do that
now okay I didn't tell you to walk just
yet so go back to the position that I
had you stand at
before left foot on the line or
two left foot on the line right foot in
front of your
left with your hands at your sides and
you're going to stand there and you're
not going to start until I tell you to
do so okay all
right but what if I'm
shaking are you cold no I'm just nous
you're nervous there's no reason to be
nervous I I get nervous I have
anxiety okay well I asked you if you had
any medical conditions that you're diag
are you diagnosed with
anxiety are you on medication for
anxiety
okay
so what you're going to do when I tell
you to begin I'm sorry I know you're
okay left foot on the
line
Right Foot In Front heel touching your
toes hands at your
side and when I tell you to begin you're
going to take nine Heel To Toe steps on
the
line I'm sorry H I can't hear up my
knees are shaking too much your knees
are shaking I you can't do that okay
we'll move forward
then okay the next one is going to be
the one leg stand you're going to stand
with your feet you're not going to do
any of them not at all okay sounds
good go ahead and walk up to my vehicle
for
me to the front of the vehicle to the
gr for me all right give me your left
hand
tiny
rest
might I'm sorry um I have I do have
medical
condition now you have a medical
condition what's
that cuz I asked you that in the
beginning go ahead and turn around and
talk to
me it's not diagnosed I don't have it
that's diagnosed um so you're not in any
medication I did um
v um I go into an anaphylactic shock and
um high and sometimes
so that's only so if if it
happens absolutely 100% do you have
anything on you that's going to poke me
or stick me vadil and you have vadil in
your pocket on you right now do you okay
do you have anything on your person
that's going to poke me or stick me I'm
going to pat you down before I put you
in my truck okay goad and turn around
for
me
probably he's probably going have to
park find a ride this
guy
yeah you want to move up um yeah I want
to move up here move this way she's move
theol car and then we'll put you in the
back right easier to get that
way you want on the other side where can
I call somebody oh when you get to the
jail they allow you calls when you get
to the jail right
[Music]
this
way tell me a little bit but what
happens next oh sir um she'll tell you
in a minute but as far as I know it
seems like you're being arrested for
driving Under the Influence
okay if the school's okay with
parking the vehicle here I'm okay with
that yeah I going figure that out cu
he's in there he's going have to find a
right home he's not going there well I
have her deal so anything else for me
I'll do a supplement yeah I'll just do a
supplement with what she told you as far
as when she stopped drinking how much
she had to drink did she answer that no
I didn't ask that she just say it was
the time she stop drinking 130 cuz you
so small she said
130 real quick hun when did you start
drinking last
night
7 700 p.m. okay rough estimate about how
much did you have to drink last night um
I had wine at the softball game and then
I had um one what no wine oh wine okay
about how much um
iup 8 oz 16 o
um 8
O um I Hader at theall probably
four and was this a draft bottle um
bottles bottles okay and three at the
bar and then what uh four probably three
four at the bar and then the
wine and you had more wine after that as
well no I not okay so
um it I have had wine I got home at
5:30 I had some wine until 7 when game
and then and
then
okay it's I just did it all when I got
back
in all right just email me your
narrative
11:03
1103 at all female 1015 in rout to cjat
has been
DUI
Lo how you
doing how are you another good day
you have your uh school ID on I
do thanks man where's the W Wing right
here other shoes right there thank
you all right I just got to get your
name I'll use the address for for the
high school for
your so give me a little bit I know you
caught over the radio but how did you
end up she came in the front they had a
student in the car y she came in the
front and when they turned around to
come back out I told her I walked over
there I said you can't come this way
because came in the wrong way right
that's the entire you know everybody
goes that way and I said just wait here
I have to wait until some of this
traffic cuz I usually don't let him but
I could spit Reed okay soon as I went to
the front she turned the wheel and
started to come at me and I was like wo
whoa whoa back it up and then I went
back to the car to tell her again you
got to wait and she never said a word
she just looked at me blank yeah and he
was the one that did all the Talking it
freaked that's all I just need how you
got contact with her and that's all all
righty thank you we'll take care of the
rest she's uh on her way to the jail how
bad was she uh she started doing the the
gopr and then she realized she was not
doing great so she was completely stop
she said I'm done she had this blank
stair just like yeah I was like w
feel bad for the daughter yep I think it
was her niece she
said yeah thank you Ma